en general hay que obtener la mayor
cantidad posible de práctica resolviendo
sistemas de ecuaciones lineales y por
eso vamos a resolver este otro sistema
de ecuaciones pero vamos a usar esta
nueva técnica de usar las matrices
aumentadas y convertir esas matrices a
su forma escalonada reducida por filas y
aquí tenemos tres ecuaciones y tres
variables aleatorias entonces va a
quedar una matriz muy bonita y pues
vamos a escribir la no
vamos a llamar
y los coeficientes de la primera
variable aleatoria son 111 entonces en
esta matriz que representa los
coeficientes de estas ecuaciones va
primero un 1-1
1 y los coeficientes de la variable ya
son 1 2 3
1 2 3
y de la variable zeta son 134 134 y
ahora ponemos la rayita que divide
y aquí ponemos a los valores del lado
derecho del igual o sea 3 0 y 2
estos son los coeficientes de la primera
ecuación estos los de la segunda y la
tercera y y así y ahora queremos
escribir esta matriz de coeficientes en
su forma escalonada reducida por filas
ahora no tenemos que aquí tenemos un 1
entonces esta entrada de aquí es una
entrada pivote y para transformar esta
matriz a su forma escalonada reducida lo
que tenemos que hacer es que en toda
esta columna de la entrada pivote haya
puros ceros o sea queremos hacer que
esta entrada sea un 0 y que esta entrada
sea un 0 entonces lo que vamos a hacer
es dejar esta ecuación tal cual como
esté
línea del igual 3
y a esta ecuación la vamos a reemplazar
por esta misma ecuación menos esta
ecuación ok así es que tenemos aquí
1 - 1 ahora si ya tenemos el 0 que es
justo lo que estábamos buscando
y ahora dos menos uno eso nos queda un 1
y 3 -1 eso nos queda un 20 menos 3 nos
quedan menos 3 menos 3 muy bien pero
también creemos que esta entrada sea
cero así es que también vamos a
reemplazar esta ecuación por esta
ecuación menos esta ecuación ok 1 menos
103 menos 124 menos 1
y menos 2 - 3 eso es menos 5 - sí
muy bien entonces ya tenemos primera
entrada pivote y la segunda entrada
pivote que además está abajo a la
derecha de la primera entrada pivote así
es que nos estamos acercando a la forma
escalonada reducida y ahora lo que
queremos es hacer que toda la columna de
esta entrada pivote sean ceros o sea
queremos hacer que ésta sea cero y que
ésta sea cero aquí ya logramos que ésta
sea cero aunque y entonces pues vamos a
volver a escribir la matriz esto es
igual
ok lo que vamos a hacer es dejar esta
fila tal cual como esta
tenemos un 0 1
no 12 la línea de división y un -3 y
ahora lo que vamos a hacer para que esta
entrada se vuelva a cero es sustituir
esta fila por esta fila menos esta fila
ok entonces tenemos 1 - 0 eso sigue
siendo un 1 y un 1 menos uno eso nos da
cero que es lo que estábamos buscando
1 - 2 eso es menos 1
y tres menos -3 eso es 33 o sea 6
ok ahora queremos hacer que esta entrada
sea 0 así es que vamos a sustituir esta
fila por esta fila menos dos veces esta
fila
0 - 2 por 0 esto sigue siendo 0
2 - 2 x 1 esos 22 o sea
y tres menos dos por dos
esos tres menos cuatro que es menos uno
menos uno y ahora menos cinco menos dos
por menos tres eso se ve muy complicado
no y no vaya a ser que le agreguemos en
las cuentas se nos vaya por ahí un menos
y echemos a perder toda la matriz y nos
queda un resultado que no tenga sentido
un resultado que no sea la solución a
este sistema de ecuaciones entonces pues
mejor para no arriesgarnos pues vamos a
escribirlo por acá no o sea tenemos
menos 5 menos 2 x menos 3 aunque yo sea
2 x menos 3
así es que pues estoy acá es menos 6 o
sea que tenemos menos 5 menos menos 6
y menos por menos de más o sea
- 56 y eso es exactamente igual a 1 ok
entonces aquí va un 1 y bueno ya casi
estamos listos esta matriz ya casi está
en su forma escalonada reducida ok pero
pero aquí no puede ser un -1 o sea la
forma escalonada reducida exige que esta
entrada de aquí sea exactamente igual a
uno no puede estar ninguna otra cosa en
esta entrada
ok entonces lo que vamos a hacer para
que realmente sea un 1 es tal cual en
lugar de volver a escribir toda la
matriz nada más multiplicar esta fila
directamente aquí en esta misma matriz x
menos 1 ok entonces 0 x menos 100 x
menos 10 menos 1 por menos 1 ahí sí ya
nos queda aún más 1
y 1 pero menos 1 nos quedan menos 1 y
ahora sí ahora sí ya tenemos puros unos
como la primera entrada distinta de 0 de
cada fila aunque hay todas las entradas
pivotes son exactamente 1 y ya nada más
el último detalle que nos falta es que
toda la columna de esta última entrada
pivote tenga puros ceros y la entrada
pivote ok entonces pues vamos a volver a
hacer la matriz y vamos a dejar esta
fila tal cual como está 0
- 1 y aquí para hacer que esta entrada
sea exactamente igual a 0 lo que vamos a
hacer es reemplazar esta fila por esta
fila menos dos veces esta fila ok
entonces
0 menos dos por cero
1 - 2 x 0 1 claramente 2 menos 2 por 1
esto es 0 porque así lo escogimos y
- 3 - 2 - 1 tampoco nos queremos
confundir en el último momento no
entonces vamos a escribir menos tres
menos dos por menos 12 por menos 1
hay dos pero menos uno es menos dos o
sea aquí tenemos menos 3 - menos 2 y
menos por menos dar más o sea menos tres
más dos ok eso es igual a menos 1
así es que aquí va un -1 y ahora vamos
con esta fila en esta ecuación y pues
para hacer que esta entrada sea 0 pues
aquí tenemos un -1 con que le sumamos la
última fila ya estamos aquí entonces 10
eso nos da un 10 más 0 nos sigue dando 0
- 1 más 10 menos mal
6 + menos 1 esos 6 menos uno que es 5
que y listo ahora sí ya la tenemos en su
forma escalonada
ok porque aquí cada fila tiene su
entrada pivote igual a 1 y además todas
están abajo y a la derecha de la
anterior que éste está a la derecha de
éste y éste está a la derecha de estos
dos y además en cada columna de una
entrada pivote el resto de las entradas
de la columna es 0 ok entonces esta si
es una matriz que está en su forma
escalonada reducida por filas forma
escalonada reducida por filas
y mira nada más no tenemos ni una sola
variable libre porque porque en cada
columna hay una entrada pivote y eso lo
que va a provocar es que todas las
variables estén perfectamente
determinadas y tengamos una solución
única ok ya vamos a regresar de una vez
al mundo de las ecuaciones esta matriz
aumentada que ecuaciones nos da pues la
primera fila nos da la ecuación 1 x x x
+ 0 porque + 0 por zeta y todo eso es
igual
mira nada más ya tenemos x exactamente
igual a 5 y la segunda fila lo que nos
da es una ecuación que tiene nada más al
ayer aunque porque tenemos 0 x x + 1
porque o sea la ye solita +0 por zeta y
eso es igual a menos 1 ya se ve aquí
como se están determinando perfectamente
las variables no y la tercera ecuación
es 0 x x 0 porque más 1 por zeta o sea
la se está solita igual a menos 1
así es que a través de las matrices
aumentadas y la forma escalonada
reducida por filas redujimos este
sistema de ecuaciones a este otro
sistema de ecuaciones y con eso ya
encontramos tal cual cuál es la solución
del sistema esta es la solución del
sistema y es una solución única y espero
que te parezca muy útil